what's happening peeps we got ourselves
a deadpool 3 update from ryan reynolds
popped up in our notification bells from
the cosmic wonder headline with deadpool
and
other mcu movies let's see what this
update is all about
what's up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder where we talk
all things marvel and mcu and today we
have some deadpool 3 news we haven't had
any in a while now
but since the movie free guy starring
ryan reynolds is coming out he's been
doing
a lot of interviews and a lot of check
out our review
about deadpool 3. which works out for us
because it gives us
answers including who might be directing
it and when we might be able to expect
the actual release of deadpool 3. so if
you want to stay up to date on deadpool
3 and the mcu be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the videos
so to start off with the great news ryan
reynolds and the molly knows sisters
have been
working on deadpool 3 pretty much every
day for a while
now it is officially in pre-development
it has been for a bit
but ryan reynolds reiterates this in an
interview with collider
when talking about developing deadpool 3
he says
it's something that is just a daily
process writing is kind of like that
you've gotta a lot time to do it and
walk away and i'm working with them all
and knows on it it's been great
they're incredibly talented and so so
smart they so understand that world and
know how to zig when everyone's
expecting a zag
so it's been a lot of fun now since
they've been working on it for a bit of
course they had to ask them
when can deadpool 3 expect to start
filming collider asked what the
percentage is that deadpool 3 starts
filming in 2022 and ryan reynolds said
this
the percentage chance i don't know i
couldn't assign a percentage to that
i'd say it's 50 50 maybe we're really
actively developing it
and getting it into pretty good shape
what the hell month is it
august oh next year probably pretty dang
good i'd say
seventy percent ryan reynolds himself
says that there's a 70
chance a pretty dang good chance in his
words that deadpool 3 starts to film in
2022 which is great news because
if that happens that means we're getting
deadpool 3 in probably
2023. that's really great news and i
imagine the development process on this
one's going to be very different because
deadpool 1
took a long time to get off the ground
with deadpool 2 it sounded like they
gave him a lot more creative liberties
of what they wanted to do and they were
kind of like no that first one was a hit
we got to get this one
out there and this one's going to have a
little bit of different work around i
imagine because
now we got him in the mcu now we got
kevin feige
involved so after they get this script
done then there's probably going to have
to be tweaks and rewrites i'd be very
surprised they were like no they just
let us do the script that we wanted to
do and that was the end of it because
now i imagine that there's going to be a
lot more producer input
on what they can or cannot do even
though it will be rated r
i imagine it's not going to be exactly
the same process
here that is raunchy and off the
deep end but yeah and also too i mean
this will give them time to ramp back up
the sort of deadpool
promotion cycle deadpool whatever ryan
reynolds is around is always sort of
evident but i feel like you know we've
actually gotten some distance from
deadpool 2. so now it's time to start
building that hype back
up let's go in fact even if they began
to film deadpool 3
in early of 2023 we could still get the
movie in 2023 which is great because
that would mean we're only about russian
and at this rate worst case scenario it
films in 2023 and we get it early 2024
which is still not
that long to wait and it's not that long
to wait because of this reason right
here deadpool can still appear in the
mcu
before his own
deadpool is actually now in the mcu kind
of making a joke about how to get into
it
any tips on uh getting into the mcu
there cork uh
have a dream uh chase it
lose that dream just sabotage all sorts
of happiness
in pursuit of that dream climb up to the
peaks of that mountain
and when you get to the top land at the
bottom and realize you're never going to
achieve that dream
and at that point check your emails
maybe you'll get something from your
agent saying
marvel wants to talk yeah i prefer dark
and ryan reynolds is definitely open to
doing that in fact in an interview with
comicbook.com's brandon davis
ryan reynolds stated that he really
actually would like to appear in other
mcu films
when asked if he would join another mcu
film or go straight to deadpool 3
ryan said i think both are pretty
warranted you always have to zig
when everybody is expecting you to zag
when it comes to that character
so i think as long as disney is open to
me having some
divergent uses of the character of
deadpool then
i'm all for it i think it would be
really cool if he was like thor love and
thunder for a moment or pops up in
multiverse of madness any of these like
multiverse films spiderman no way home
does not seem likely to me
multiverse of madness i'm sure they
could find a way to make it work for
even a split second
how exciting would that be well in a way
that might lend legitimacy to how
deadpool exists within the universe too
because now we have
so much more sort of craziness for him
to pierce through and to
trust between i feel like most people
would be really excited about that but i
know that there'd be a pretty good chunk
of the audience i'd be like ah he would
steal too much of the spotlight or be
too much of the conversation if he makes
any cameo whatsoever
but i'm down for it i don't care i want
him in anything i think it's great
so just because deadpool might not be
coming for another two to three years
doesn't mean that we won't see him
before then
in the actual mcu especially since the
multiverse is a thing now i'd actually
really love for deadpool to pop up and
make a joke about the multiverse how
he's from the fox universe even just a
quick
five second cameo i think would be
hilarious now last but not least it
looks like
deadpool 3 could have found its director
already and it comes in the form of the
director from ryan reynolds's movie
free guy now i will say oh that would be
awesome i would love that super shot
there are actually many superhero easter
eggs all throughout the movie and some
fun cameos
and the director is sean levy and during
the interviews sean levy was asked if he
is
interested in working with marvel and
the rumors are that he is going to
direct deadpool 3 and he was asked if
there is any truth to those rumors
in which he literally said quote i'm
going to mostly skirt that question
which is not the werewolf
hey i'm gonna avoid this question which
is basically me telling you my answer
yes i mean he just worked with ryan
reynolds on free guy
it's basically a deadpool type of movie
the humor is pretty on par with it not
so many crude jokes but still
it's not official yet but it looks like
deadpool 3 has found their director
in sean levy if you guys watch free guy
i think you would be
very much excited at the prospect of him
like as much as ward is correlating
drawing a parallel here between
the type of film that deadpool is and
free guy i think they're very different
ultimately beyond just one being pg-13
and one being rated r
i still think they're very different
films and i feel like though with sean
levy's
uh capabilities of what we've seen do in
the past he would be
a great great director a wonderful
addition to the director pool
of deadpool undoubtably yeah i'd be very
much excited at the prospect of that
especially after free guy
so a lot happening for deadpool 3 it's
well underway
in development right now and ryan
reynolds feels like it's a pretty dang
good possibility that it's going to
start filming next year which hopefully
means we only have a couple of years to
wait for it so let me know your thoughts
on this awesome
deadpool 3 news in the comments down
below and if you're interested in free
guy i recently interviewed pokemane and
ninja who are both in the movie and are
two of the biggest gamers of all time
you can find that link in the
description or up above
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me
thank you instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof that was a very exciting
update there was a lot in there to
unpack very excited about it guys who
would you want to direct deadpool 3
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to cost wonder if you haven't done so
already you can subscribe to us
hit that like button last but not least
deontay w tongue punch fart box
there was a world within the mcu that
was made for
you i think this is the one deadpool i
would love to see you become his new
companion or something like that
a more likable version of russell from
the last movie you know
plus you could finally strut out your
signature
fart box move and have it personified
like a cartoon with all sorts of crazy
cgi but the thing is
they would also imbue you with a whole
lot of heart so you know even though
you're a bit of a rascal we would come
to love you by the end of the movie who
knows maybe even
spin you off into your own franchise
disney plus series
you know a one shot deontay
i just want this for you so badly so uh
hey
appreciate your pledge and uh you know
keep at that
tongue punch fart box magic that you
have
keep tongue punching fart boxes
because you know deadpool's into that
too so you guys could probably hook up